if the host is trend for the colder
months so first but can you trust that
what you're being sold is really
synthetics a Sky News investigation has
found real animal fur being sold on the
British High Street but falsely
advertised to shoppers as fake and we
aren't talking back alleys we hit the
most famous shopping streets in the UK
with a head of an animal protection
charity even flagship big name stores
who assured us they had strict no fur
policies were myth selling products
these felt really soft it's just a hoax
we're not allowed to tell anything with
real fur so we've just bought these
gloves I think for display fur that's
only 30 pounds what do you think
actually made them so it's definitely
real and life comes cheap in Asia's fur
farms and say you can pick up real fur
in the UK at bargain basement prices
[Music]
definitely gonna buy firm but we came
out with a pair of shoes and a beanie
which were not fake but the real deal
the vast majority of people wouldn't
think that you could get this much in
this case it says Made in China all
synthetic mm-hmm but this is certainly
not synthetic we also bought several
pairs of shoes from fast fashion outlet
misguided and had our shopping haul
tested by a fibers expert so we sent you
the items from our shopping trip and
what did you find I found that they're
all genuine animal fur and that there
were a range of species I found rabbit
raccoon dog cat and linked in your
experience how common is it to find
these species on the high street it's
becoming increasingly common
particularly I would say over the past
five years rabbit is fairly common and
mink is moderately common
cut is highly unusual these shapes and
these distances and the profiles of
prominence everything is characteristic
of cat the raccoon dog is become not
common you might not have seen this
creature before but its fur has been
creeping into retail supply chains
passes a one-year-old raccoon dog if you
see his fur coat here and have a feed of
it it's really soft and dense and it's
that soft dense fur which not only keeps
him safe in his in the harsh climates of
Southeast Asia but it also makes him
quite peed into the fur trade
that combined with massive litters of
anywhere up to 16 individuals from one
set of parents they are being mass
farmed now and often skinned alive
it's that cruelty that fashion animal
leather Donna has always tried to avoid
I love clothes I've never ever knowingly
buy fur it's not so look I agree with at
all she bought the misguided shoes and
immediately suspected they were real fur
touching it was just too soft too animal
like for it to be fake I knew in an
instant through but basically looking at
the skin that was backed onto that I
could see its Pelt and it's not fabric
so that's when I challenged the retailer
asking them why this was and could they
investigate it please I was hoping
they'd take it more seriously but they
dismissed it as being faux so you're
right we have the items tested and the
shoes came back as most consistent with
cat fur cat fur really my life is
basically animals and cats so it's it's
really hurtful really shocking whether
they know they're selling it or not
either way there needs to be something
done about it they need to be more
responsible for what they're selling
we contacted the retailers with our
findings none would appear on camera
misguided said they'll be launched an
internal investigation with the relevant
suppliers and will ensure these matters
are addressed urgently how's the phrase
they told us they have a strict no fur
policy and were never knowingly mislead
customers they take this issue very
seriously and have communicated this to
the brand in question all products that
he removed from sale and refunds will be
offered fur farms were banned in the UK
in 2003
but despite changing tastes the fur
trade is still not out of British
fashion Zara HBGary Sky News